[Music]
in wrap it up news
rapper submitted by brickies butthole
hey my little uncle Oh God
don't go breaking oh that's your uncle
knows uncle is in Korean the wink
relationship with her uncle no it's not
about walking breeki what soul I sense
their tail is up her butthole is always
moist and sticking out so when I'm
handling all three dogs like I have to
make sure to not never cross the leash
behind or else that whole leash would
just [ __ ] be like a violin on above
all oh my god cousin later have to take
it off I just saw I'm always like
watching out how I'm walking Oh buddy
you play like double dutch with the
[ __ ] Lee oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't want
to [ __ ] floss her butthole what the
[ __ ] leash so know what she wants to
poop cuz then her butt starts like looks
like the opening and closing you know
I'm so gross yeah we're like oh damn
she's got sack of [ __ ]
Maddy does that too I know when she's
about to she's her tail up like that
like this way can act you are so
interesting like even like do Tyson's
[ __ ] huge right now I just called
Tyson I can't remember it it's been so
many years I cannot call a meatloaf he
looks just like I said another thing if
you if I show you picture fights in gym
or black but now that he got fatter he
looks more like Tyson even got fatter
yeah he's hella fat now if you know
those [ __ ] chunky didn't every day
he's pretty big like a punching bag
horizontally oh looks like Tyson I keep
people on forgetting did meet no my meat
loaf
even him like his habit of biting you
when he wants attention yeah it's so
exciting
yeah I just [ __ ] nibbles at your
[ __ ] penises [ __ ] I'm like oh stop
he's a prick STD rates in California
just hit a record-high what the [ __ ]
have something to celebrate about you
know though with all the education that
we have I feel like they count chlamydia
as an STD way too much cuz like that
sure
Psalms immediately they got that super
gonorrhea now though I think that social
media maybe everybody [ __ ] so much so
DMing each other way more people are
able to hook up Weibull yeah yeah yeah
yeah no girls are way more uh probably
liberated yeah sexually ever liberated
so people are like no it's just that you
see I'm wearing your face but we were
always like that I don't think so
because it's the highest oh yeah you're
right and and culturally it's kind of
strange we're like I remember back in
our days like you would want to work
towards sex yeah now I hear it's so
commonplace for me to hear people talk
about alright we [ __ ] on the first
night and also you want to get together
yeah I'm gonna be their girlfriend or
boyfriend whatever I'm like wow that's
so bad yeah intimacy is the opposite
yeah it's like [ __ ] is completely
okay I'll [ __ ] jizz in the mouth or
whatever but I don't know I watch a
movie with them that's so weird
we're becoming brazilian I'm not we were
just like we're just like was definitely
definitely thought I was gonna wait till
marriage to have sex when I was but
you're like jacking off everywhere
though how the [ __ ] know it was waiting
till marriage David that was the way to
yeah I also thought that if you did anal
that you kept your rigid yeah but it
hurts so I hate loops I went in I was
like get it out like it was a demon
remember I just set that [ __ ] did I I
was just mentioning this [ __ ] Catholic
girls man cuz you had actual sex you
were bad girl I had sex when I was 19 oh
that's right how old are you
I win you like that girl it's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was honor our one-year
anniversary I swear
to get married only eight times away how
long have you been dating that guy ah at
least a year [ __ ] you like the first
hour hi boyfriend so I why I nearly
getting married oh we like it was on our
one-year anniversary but I was like I'm
definitely gonna marry him so as counts
like we'd at sixteen I wasn't that down
oh are you doing this is like I must
save myself for marriage you get your
boyfriend in the first now really listen
I do not want to have sex at all no
basically we did like si mind all the
time he did everything but sex cuz I was
like I was like nope that's for marriage
I was saying like last week in a
previous video there was a church leader
of mine that I met later on and then you
know we're more open now and I said like
hey yo like like I need you like [ __ ]
around and [ __ ] like that
yeah I didn't have cell diversionists
because she said that she was a virgin
because the guy didn't come inside her
it's like these weird like rules they
make it up yeah
his sperm never reached my always
considered virginity yes ridiculous hmm
the opposite I couldn't wait to get rid
of it
Thanks so anyway like it's a mole wait
it was a bad bad like I picked the guy
but anyway so California releases 2017
data and now they're saying that there
has been a 45 percent increase computed
that is a over 300,000 cases of
chlamydia gonorrhea and early stage
syphilis about 30 syphilis related
stillborns have been reported which is
the highest in the last 20 years what
this was stillborn sounds kind of sad be
like guys because they got syphilis
coming out yo did you see those old pics
I'm not sure if it was syphilis or
gonorrhea but it was like an STD that
was passed on to the child and if the
child
yeah that's why even now they put
ointment on the baby as soon as it just
in case yeah and then I think be like I
got checked for STDs like all the
[ __ ] time they'd have to take like
cultures and then they [ __ ] run it in
the lab and then as soon as that's not
when you see their newborns they have
that gel on their face
oh yeah it's to protect just in case
yeah if you look up that little bit dude
that [ __ ] broke my heart dude it's so
sick I just want to [ __ ] everything
and peel it off and [ __ ] oh yeah so
messy
you're right though how you're saying
like they can't chlamydia a lot because
they're saying two-thirds of the cases
were all chlamydia yeah college kids
college kids
I loved grew up in a college town and we
had the densest population of STD in the
state in that one mile square radius
yeah because if you wanna [ __ ] go to UCS
yeah that was the first time I ever went
into a college town and it looked like
legit the way the movies do it yeah I've
never seen it like that I thought USC we
had that row and I was like oh yeah but
then I went to Santa Barbara I'm like oh
[ __ ] this is what they face yeah Santa
Barbara's [ __ ] Halloween bar do they
like block it all up but so Santa
Barbara locals don't consider Isla Vista
to be part of Santa Barbara that's like
the college area and we say oh yeah
that's gross but like if those fools are
so my cousin was that inner frat at us
UCSB yeah their frat house and since
were there one of the newer frats they
didn't have a pool
but they wanted to have a pool party so
what they end up doing is they dug a
big-ass hole in the volleyball court put
a tarp over and filled it up with water
and I'm like you guys are so [ __ ]
genius but you can't find a job
playable pools not the same to get like
50 girls in there they need they need
the volleyball court they needed
something that big that's how [ __ ]
gee I'm like you guys are so creative
and you can't get a [ __ ] job did you
guys go and see that no who's just
telling me otherwise all the [ __ ]
dirt outside of volleyball houses
they're not motivated by money they're
motivated by poster yeah so you gotta
tell them like all right what are you
gonna do
all the STDs yeah see the though I just
went on a couple of college shows
recently and they were telling me just
like casually they're like oh yeah like
there was like a huge like pink I see
that was gone oh my god what the [ __ ]
are you rubbing your [ __ ] on each
other the whole time like oh and also
like before that everybody was getting
mono and I'm like you guys are [ __ ]
nasty I don't know [ __ ] about STDs
meaning in that [ __ ] they're just
they're just rampant everywhere but I
understand because I went to a house
party after it's just everybody's up on
you dude I got scared the older I got
cuz you know the older you get like the
more percentage of people have STDs and
then like the more people they [ __ ]
right and I just like dormant once -
yeah there's like no symptoms so I was
single I was like oh now I gotta take
from this pool the cesspool of STD
filled people yeah because there's that
whole thing where they were just putting
articles about like HPV yeah yeah that's
almost people have you know why because
it goes through condoms and so the guys
don't know there cares there's no way to
tell if a guy has it yeah there's no way
to tell if a guy has it unless he gets
tested and then yeah and then there's a
hundred different strains but there's
only thirteen of those strains are
malignant that could cause cancer how do
you know so much about this cuz I have
it but like yeah but when I read the
percentage but it I got the one that's
not malignant and it went through a
condom I was safe I was very safe yeah
you just never know this is one of those
things like it's like people been having
for the longest time and then they
finally defined it you know what it was
and so like I remember oh my god what
the [ __ ] is going on and it was like it
makes it scary 80% of people have
everybody basically everybody unless you
don't [ __ ] yeah yeah those twenty
percent of people we're going to [ __ ]
them eventually yeah that's like being
lactose intolerance and can be dormant
too so like the guy I guess got tested
and it was like fine then you got tested
later and it wasn't fine anymore cuz
like you if you [ __ ] a girl that has it
then you have it but you don't know that
you have it and then it comes out later
it's like so weird yeah and like most
guys too apparently though they'll get
like what they can get from is like
testicular cancer or like or some [ __ ]
like that but it's like 2% it's like
super [ __ ]
no no that's why you have to get the
Gardasil shot or whatever they'd like a
[ __ ] sizable animation yeah but
you'll have to get it before you
contract it though right yeah you have
to get it before you get it but if you
so they were saying cuz I got one of the
strains that was benign but if I wanted
to get it now to prevent the other one
other ones from happening then you can
still you get it out of physical so now
they started giving it as part of the
regular vaccinations for when that
people are younger but you know because
we're a little bit older like they
didn't have that back then I mean it's
like three hundred dollars or shot and
you to go three times but water
molecules don't even go through condoms
issue oh no maybe it's like in the air
no but you're right about the chlamydia
thing cuz they're saying that more than
half of the comitia catching the cold I
had that several times if it's curable I
don't feel like it's a should be counted
as a SCA a really good Thursday I mean
the fact that it's forty five percent
increase in the last five years that
they're saying that public health
officials are they're saying that is
because of a lack of awareness yeah
that's why this is going okay like for
example like if you have sex with a new
partner a lot of times if you're prone
to UTIs you can get a UTI very easily
but I don't consider that an STD yeah
even they do categorize as UTI right who
the ADIZ dude it's uh it's like not
considered an STD it's like just an
infection the yeast infection consider
because it could be like um like I'm
like they're the guys pH pre-cum or
whatever balance well and I can also you
can get it just from having paint new
pants but you don't but you know rub a
certain way or whatever it is or if you
workout too much yeah you can get it
from a lot of different things so it's
not considering Raffi like that's a STD
right but it's yeah I mean crabs exist
that much anymore since no one is
accusing yes
you get crabs crabs crabs I just think
you play a clip first buy a house oh I
think and they tell me they read the
news every day did you hear more and
more homes are getting burned every day
just doesn't sound good for us we got to
stop this pubic-hair deforestation yeah
crabs gonna live now
[Music]
[Music]